bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 5 avril concernant la situation au
kosovo et dans les pays limitrophes il
semble que l'otan ait corrigé sa
stratégie sur le plan humanitaire nous
verrons comment les réfugiés kosovars
installés à la frontière la macédoine à
blatche et survivent dans des conditions
dramatiques
un vaste dispositif d aide humanitaire
se met petit à petit en place aussi bien
en macédoine qu'en albanie
nous retrouverons bertrand cocq à tirana
et benoît duquesne à couquèques le
président de la république d'albanie
mesure est chef danny interviendra en
direct de tirana au monténégro les
réfugiés ne bénéficient pas des mêmes
secours nous serons en direct de
podgorica avec maryse burgot changement
de stratégie également avec une
intensification des frappes des avions
de l'otan serbie nous recevrons pour
évoquer le sort des réfugiés kosovars
monsieur bernard kouchner enfin parmi
les autres types de l'actualité
l'arrivée des deux suspects libyens à la
mc2 présumés auteurs de l'attentât
contre un avion de la panam en décembre
88 qui avait fait 270 morts seront jugés
plus de dix ans après les faits la
campagne électorale présidentielle en
algérie quatre candidats signent un
pacte pour lutter contre la fraude
électorale
football demain marseille jeu contre le
club italien de bologne en demi-finale
de coupe d'europe pour trait de
l'entraîneur marseillais
rolland courbis alors ce ne sont que des
chiffres mais ils donnent l'ampleur du
drame humanitaire des réfugiés du kosovo
entre 350 et 400 mille personnes ont
quitté le kosovo depuis le début des
frappes de l'otan
le 24 mars la répartition des réfugiés
et comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
carte inégale en macédoine selon le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés il y aurait au
moins 115 mille peut être plus personne
totalement démunis qui sont arrivés dans
ce pays le gouvernement macédoine n'a de
cesse d'appeler à l'aide
et d'évoquer les risques de
déstabilisation démographique mais c'est
à black chez à la frontière macédonienne
que les conditions de survie des
réfugiés sont les plus terribles
les premières aides alimentaires du pain
du sud par exemple ont été reçus dans
une grande pagaille
mais peu à peu les vingt mille femmes
hommes enfants bébés ou vieillards
entassés sur moins d'un kilomètre carré
s'organise dans une attente sans
illusion car de l'autre côté de la
frontière
des dizaines de milliers de nouveaux
kosovars affamés sont bloqués reportage
et en bonis andreï saura avoir à moi à
chaque distribution de nourriture
ceux qui en ont encore la force se
bousculent la foule de ces survivants
s'est encore agrandie aujourd'hui de
deux trains venus du kosovo ils sont
vingt à trente mille dans ce cloaque
ils n'ont pas mangé depuis trois ou
quatre jours
regardez tout le monde crève de faim il
y aura le typhus
c'est une ville de tentes qui a poussé
sur cette frontière entre le kosovo et
la macédoine
la plupart de ces réfugiés viennent de
pristina aujourd'hui désertée par ses
albanais ils attendent que les autorités
macédoniennes veuille bien les laisser
entrer je suis depuis cinq jours c'est
très dangereux c'est très difficile vous
voyez toutes les cinq minutes une
personne épuisé les sorties de ce vallon
c'est une honte
nous sommes en europe vous voyez dans
quelles conditions nous vivons comme des
animaux pas comme des humains tous les
autocars de macédoine sont
réquisitionnés pour conduire les plus
chanceux vers des camps de transit
les forces de l'otan ont déjà apporté 75
mille tonnes de matériel et d'aidé
alimentaire pour essayer de pallier les
effets de l' escalade militaire dont
l'alliance atlantique a pris la
responsabilité
dépassant cette région si les troupes de
l'otan vont kosovo nous y retournerons
s'ils n'ont sûrement pas le premier
ministre macédonien du relief qui compte
sur les pays de l'otan pour accueillir
certains de ces réfugiés mais chacun
sait qu'ils n'ont pas fini de piétiner
sans destination sans avenir
oui alors nous allons maintenant aller
en albanie où le nombre de réfugiés est
estimé hier à 204 mille et c'est dans la
région frontalière du nord de l'albanie
que les demandes de vivres et de
médicaments sont les plus importantes
les organisations humanitaires ne
dispose de produits alimentaires que
pour 36 heures au maximum
reportage benoît duquesne et didier da
pour un lundi de pâques pourquoi pas un
jardin une pelouse des enfants qui
jouent et des bourgeois en fleuve
pourquoi pas si pâques signifie vraiment
quelque chose ici et si la guerre
n'était pas si proche nous sommes loin
de kukes loin de la frontière et des
colonnes de réfugiés
nous sommes à nong un village tranquille
de 15 cents habitants dont la population
a presque triplé en quelques jours
eux sont réfugiés arrivés dès les
premiers temps on les a conduits ici
dans cette maison où ils attendent sans
trop savoir quoi faire
nous remercions les gens d'ici 14
couchages cas égales il n'entend
accueillis comme des frères
on partage leur troisième finale à nous
les remercions pour cela ils ne nous ont
pas laissés dehors sous la pluie les
conditions de vie une expression pudique
pour décrire bien peu de choses comme
les autres ils ont dû quitter leurs
villages dans la précipitation une
demi-heure pour jeter ce qu'il pouvait
dans la remorque de leurs facteurs comme
les autres les serbes auront pris leur
argent à la frontière alors il faut
compter sur la générosité mais l'aide
tarde à arriver
on a besoin de médicaments parce qu'on a
rien ici rien du tout on vit dans de
très mauvaises conditions
on n'a pas de vêtements pas de place
pour dormir
pas de toilettes si ça continue on va
attraper des maladies
cinq familles 80 personnes vivent dans
deux pièces comme celle ci elle y
dorment dimanche s'il avait 80 femmes
hommes vieillards et enfants qui ne
savent même pas ce qu'est devenu leur
village au kosovo pour l'instant
l'argent qu'ils ont pu sauver la
solidarité albanaise leur ont permis de
tenir mais le village lui-même ne peut
plus suivre les albanais sont plus
pauvres que et leur présence pèse trop
lourd
le maire sont inquiètes même note comme
marchandise
il nous faut beaucoup plus d'être parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont plus de
vêtements ici et l'a projeté ils ont
besoin de couvertures de nourriture
la situation est bien sûr très difficile
pour elle et pour nous aussi nous
n'avons pas les moyens de supporter une
telle charge et notre situation
s'aggrave aussi et le village de langue
est à l'image de l'albanie jusqu'ici la
solidarité a joué mais le pays ne peut
plus absorber de réfugiés ses faibles
capacités sont épuisés on a besoin du
kent si je comprends mais le plus dur
reste à venir c'est maintenant dans les
jours à venir dans les semaines à venir
car ça va continuer cette situation tout
à fait dans l'immédiat si vous voulez
les ambitions humanitaire le hcr sont
relativement moins pessimistes qu'il ne
l'était il ya quelques jours ils pensent
que le spectre d'une catastrophe
humanitaire au sens où l'entend
habituellement s'était éloigné parce que
eh bien laide fini par arriver le pont
aérien se mettent en place des camps
sombre et c est donc en tout cas ici
dans la région de fougasses les choses
s'améliorent même s'il y a
pas loin d'ici par exemple à trois
heures de piste une autre frontière où
on sait que des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés arrivent dans des conditions
beaucoup plus dramatique donc dans
l'immédiat les choses s'améliorent mais
à terme les choses reste très
préoccupante pourquoi il vient tout
simplement il suffit de regarder les
chiffres
il y a constamment environ 30 35 mille
personnes qui arrivent ici du kosovo
dans ce pays de près de 3 millions
d'habitants si le fo sauvons et vider
entièrement que ça semble être la
tension milosevic ça va faire un million
un million et demi de personnes qui vont
arriver
on connaît la situation de l'albanie on
sait ces structures que son économie
sont plus que défaillante et se paie
fille ce pays ne peut pas supporter une
telle charge c'est non seulement
l'ensemble des réfugiés qu'il va falloir
supporter mais c'est aussi le pays
lui-même qu'il va falloir tenir à bout
de bras
merci venoix lorsqu'on appelle le pont
aérien humanitaire commence actuellement
sur l'aéroport de tirana la capitale où
il faut combiner la rigueur militaire et
puis le système d'aidé organismes de
secours
reportage bertrand cocq et roger motte
depuis 24 heures maintenant
ça n'arrête pas transall après recul
civiles et militaires les appareils se
pose et posent leurs cargaisons puis
redécolle 9 transall cet après midi 70
tonnes dead et de matériel improvisation
système d les français sont à leur
affaire
on a récupéré des voitures pour enfin
bouger surtout on a récupéré le prête
pas d'alimentaire on a de l'eau parce
que ceux qui vont puisque ce qui manque
la hausse et l'eau ça c'est quand même
important c'est pour gros le ferai quand
même
on a des véhicules obligé d téléphone
pour téléphoner donc ça va quand même
aller beaucoup mieux
les américains sont là aussi ils sont 40
bientôt 400 installé en bord de piste à
côté des français ils vont construire un
camp relais pour l'aide internationale
l'instant avec les français en
travaillent côte à côte mais j'espère
qu'à l'avenir on pourra former une
coalition et faire ce boulot ensemble
les français disposent de trois
hélicoptères trois hélicoptères
seulement pour acheminer là-haut dans le
nord une pincée d aide humanitaire
c'est un fil ténu une chaîne où chacun
met la main
france qui est environ 500
pour un nouvel aller retour tir à la
conquête
à la troisième là maintenant on essaye
d'en faire encore deux dans la prière
par la route c'est plus de 12
le puma et les deux coups gardons mettre
une demi heure à travers la montagne
pour rallier kukes à la frontière du
kosovo
à l'arrivée pas de réfugiés mais des
italiens de la sécurité civile ce sont
eux qui réceptionne l'aide apportée par
les français la montée 500 ans pour
accueillir 3000 réfugiés maintenant
qu'on a on donne un coup de main aux
français pour décharger les vivent ces
classes maintenant on va les faire
parvenir au camp avant tir en corse et
marsouins était applaudi chez en bosnie
et jusqu'à ce matin le premier casse
tête de leur capitaine c'était le manque
de kérosène
maintenant qu'on a du kérosène voir mon
avis cinq ou six rotations sans aucun
problème maintenant après ça va dépendre
de ce qu'on va nous donner à faire et
nous la presse mais comme problème de
potentiel et de carburant et ses tours
ce matin ya eu 5 tonnes la nouveau il ya
cinq tonnes et puis ça a continué dans
la journée et puis demain à peine 5
tonnes dead à chaque rotation une demi
heure sur place
cuire au décollage ce soir le puma et
les deux cougar sont encore le seul lien
de l'europe avec les réfugiés du nord de
l'albanie
lesur et chef medjani vous êtes le
président de république d'albanie merci
d'avoir accepté de nous parler en direct
de tirana quels types d' aide concrète a
besoin votre pays actuellement
on a besoin de beaucoup de choses parce
que le peuple albanais la nation
albanaise se trouve face aux un problème
assez grave qui est peut-être le plus
grave depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais je crois aussi que le mécanisme
international a commencé à bouger pour
nous aider alors pensez vous qu'il fait
y effectivement organiser un transfert
de population vers d'autres pays que le
vôtre vous souhaitez vous que l'on
organise sur place c'était
internationale moi je crois au début il
faut organiser la situation sur place
c'est-à-dire ces gens des portes et
doivent rester dans la région pour avoir
une possibilité vite de se retourner
chez eux
craignez-vous une déstabilisation de
l'albanie notamment compte tenu du rôle
que peuvent jouer certains militants de
loups checa militaire de l'ofce cas sur
le territoire albanais non je pense pas
seulement s'il ya des gens qui sont en
filtrer par le service de belgrade
mais toute façon on travaille au dessus
et il y a
un travail qui est aussi en
collaboration avec les albanais qui sont
venus en albanie sur l'aide humanitaire
dont vous avez besoin c'est plus une
aide médicale une aide alimentaire ou de
la logistique pour installer un camp
pour mettre en place les moyens
d'accueillir mieux les populations
moi je crois pour toutes les choses
parce que aussi on a besoin d'eux quand
on a besoin d'une logistique assez
préparés aussi des aides alimentaires et
des aides médicales aussi souhaitez-vous
une intervention terrestre des forces de
l'otan pour envahir d'une certaine
manière le territoire du kosovo et
repousser les l'armée serbe
je crois que ça va venir aussi
mais est-ce que vous l'a souhaité cette
cette opération terrestre
ce que je souhaitais deux interrupteurs
ce génocide cette épuration ethnique qui
fait et organisé par belgrade par cette
machinerie de guerre qu'a créé beaucoup
de problèmes dont les balcons
mais d'après vous est-ce que seuls les
bombardements actuels peuvent résoudre
la crise
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin je
crois qu'il faut accélérer il faut
réaliser toutes les options possibles
pour sauver les vies même
particulièrement il y a beaucoup de gens
des albanais qui vivent dans les
montagnes dont la région de kosovars et
ils sont dans le ciel ouvert sont les
moyens alimentaires aussi votre pays est
l'un des plus pauvres que l'on connaisse
dans la région europe si le dire est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut aussi une
aide financière de l'union européenne
une aide plus matérielles pour l'étal
van hecke
oui en effet il ya une coopération assez
étroite avec le
l'union européenne je crois ce pays va
être aidé et puis c'est aussi le balcon
qui va être aidé par un plan général
pour établir un ordre nouveau
une nouvelle démocratie et une économie
forte aussi dans les pays de balcon
merci monsieur le président nous avait
accordé cet entretien d'avoir répondu en
français à nos questions merci
alors concernant l'aide humanitaire
telle qu'elle est organisée notamment en
territoire macédonien une partie de
l'aide française est arrivée aujourd'hui
voyez le reportage de valérie fournioux
et frédéric basket dès 6h30 ce matin les
premières palettes contenant des
couvertures des tentes des biscuits et
même des biberons ont été chargés dans
le ventre des c 130 de l'armée française
à destination de l'allemagne et de la
macédoine dans l'urgence à la base
d'istres l'unité de mesure et la tonne
aux estimations ce thread hollande 120
tonnes je dépasserai déjà les 100 tonnes
jour
sur ces 120 tonnes pour compter 60 à 80
tonnes l'humanitaire est également
le land 40 d'hommes qui sont des
matériels aéroportuaire qu'on va envoyer
là-bas pour renforcer les structures sur
place cet avion se dirige vers la
macédoine le vol va durer une heure de
plus que prévu car l'espace aérien
autour du kosovo est surchargé et
surtout les vols les raids contre la
serbie sont prioritaires comme les
autres sans qui ce verrou de la brique
aléatoire de la serbie on est obligé de
contourner certaines zones de manière à
pas interférer avec les autres
opérations ce qui nous amène voilà ce
que nous amène à presser
des itinéraires j'ai pas différent
arrivé sur skopje là les avions français
rejoignent ceux de l'alliance 18 au
total ont fait la navette aujourd'hui
plus de 300 tonnes ont pu être
acheminées mais l'aéroport est trop
petit et le trafic trop dense
chaque avion doit se poser des chargées
et redécollé en une heure le pont
humanitaire qui commence réellement
aujourd'hui fonctionnent à flux tendu
alors ce soir l'évacuation aérienne des
réfugiés du kosovo de macédoine a
commencé vers la turquie pour mieux
comprendre les craintes des autorités de
macédoine qui craint une déstabilisation
démographique de leur pays il faut tout
d'abord voir le nombre de réfugiés 115
villes personnes sont réfugiées
actuellement en macédoine c'est un état
qui compte 2 millions d'habitants
il est donc fragilisés par cet exode des
kosovars commentaires anne consigny et
parce que la macédoine est un petit pays
qu'elle craint l'afflux des réfugiés du
kosovo 2 millions cent quatre-vingt
mille habitants comprenant à peu près
30% des albanais et 60% de macédoniens
slave comme les serbes l'arrivée ces
derniers temps de 115 mille réfugiés
albanais sur une population
d'approximativement 700000 albanais
n'est donc pas négligeable d'autant
qu'ils sont tous concentrés dans la zone
ici en rouge le long de la frontière du
kosovo et dans cette région ils sont
largement majoritaires
les macédoniens se méfient de leurs
velléités d'autonomie voire
d'indépendance
ici en juillet 97 l'interdiction du
drapeau albanais avaient provoqué des
manifestations violemment réprimées
trois personnes avaient été tuées par la
suite la tension politique entre les
deux communautés est un peu retombée
depuis les élections législatives de
novembre le parti démocratique des
albanais détient cinq postes
ministériels n'empêche dès le début des
frappes en yougoslavie voisine
les macédoniens manifester en attaquant
l'ambassade américaine
il craignait que le conflit ne
déstabilise leur pays par un afflux de
réfugiés
la macédoine est en outre un pays en
crise économique le chômage qui touche
40% de la population
le monténégro est également touché par
l'afflux de réfugiés plus de 33000 sans
doute mais ce pays toujours lié à la
serbie dans le cadre de la république
fédérale de yougoslavie très mal les
frappes de l'otan sur une place du
centre de la capitale podgorica
chaque soir un concert folk est organisé
devant des milliers de personnes pour
protester contre des bombardements de
l'otan
le président du monténégro a nettement
marqué ses distances avec monsieur
milosevic refusant de reconnaître la
déclaration d'état de guerre faite par
belgrade
mais c'est une position fragile
difficile et les rumeurs de tentative de
coup d'état organisé par les dirigeants
serbes sont nombreuses d'autant que les
militaires serbes eux sont très présents
reportage
maryse burgot et gilles jacquet c'est
une belle journée de printemps à
podgorica la capitale du monténégro une
terrasse de café sont joyeusement bondé
pas question pour ces gens d'accepter
l'état de guerre proclamée par milosevic
la petite république du monténégro fait
certes partie intégrante de la
yougoslavie
mais aujourd'hui elle s'en démarque
regardez tous ces gens ils sont tous
très très heureux ils veulent vivre leur
vie ils sont jeunes ils veulent en
profiter et ne pas vivre avec des
meneurs nous nous voulons nous asseoir
dans les bars et voir les touristes
venir une position claire qui n'empêche
pas les monténégrins de condamner les
frappes de l'otan
une partie non négligeable d'entre eux
environ 20% restent d'ailleurs fidèle à
milosevic et sont prêts à se battre pour
le fun nous ne sommes pas encore
mobilisés seule la défense anti-aérienne
est mobilisé pour l'instant c'est quand
les troupes au sol arriverons nous irons
malgré ce courant minoritaire crown dbx
les monténégrins ont envoyé en 97
un libéral à la présidence de leur
république aujourd'hui le palais de ce
président démocrate est d'ailleurs très
protégé des rumeurs concernant un coup
d'état imminent fomenté par l'arménie
lodevic ne s'éteigne pas mais les
monténégrins sont bien décidés à se
défendre notre police forte notre peuple
est prêt à faire bloc pour un mouvement
de révolution et pour sauvegarder la
démocratie au monténégro
dans les rues l'armée c'est des rails
fidèles à milosevic et pourtant pour lui
présente et elle affiche la couleur
nous n'accepterons pas d'y ces zones que
le monténégro se détache de la
yougoslavie
le monténégro est aujourd'hui dans la
c'est à dire avec la serbie et il doit
le rester
c'est le même état le monténégro se
trouve en fait aujourd'hui dans une
position très inconfortable
il est certes opposé à milosevic mais
parce qu'il fait partie de la
yougoslavie
il n'est pas et ne sera jamais un allié
de le temps normal nous revenons sur la
situation des réfugiés du kosovo au
monténégro pour eux pas question d'une
aide humanitaire semblable à celle qui
se met en place en macédoine et en
albanie 8 l'aude il ya ici à peu près 42
mille réfugiés
c'est une situation suffisamment
inquiétante pour que le ministre de la
santé et dit ce matin qu'une catastrophe
humanitaire était peut-être à venir
alors il est évidemment ici hors de
question d'imaginer un pont aérien comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui en macédoine ou
en allemagne et nous sommes ici au
monténégro c'est une petite république
qui certes a pris ses distances par
rapport à slobodan milosevic
mais c'est une petite république qui
fait partie intégrante de la yougoslavie
et en ce sens il n'est pas possible
d'imaginer si une intervention de l'otan
pour venir secourir ces réfugiés
albanais alors il faut espérer que cet
afflux de réfugiés ne viendra pas
perturber le fragile équilibre de cette
petite république
une petite république qui jouxte la
serbie mais qui est aujourd'hui une
démocratie
merci maryse concernant maintenant
l'aspect militaire l'aviation de l'otan
a frappé fort la nuit dernière en
territoire serbe
les cibles incluait des sites militaires
mais aussi d'autres bâtiments
indirectement ou directement liée à
l'effort de guerre serbe mais on reste
dans le flou quasi totale sur le nombre
de victimes blessés ou morts causées par
ces nouveaux bombardements commentaires
françois cornut
mais radiatif la nuit dernière les
tomahawk tirés des navires de guerre
américains vont s'abattre sur les
faubourgs de belgrade
cible visée les bâtiments de
commandement de l'armée de l'air et la
défense anti-aérienne yougoslave au nord
ouest de la capitale et l'aéroport
international situé à une quinzaine de
kilomètres du centre de la ville
des raids menés simultanément par les
missiles de croisière et les chasseurs
bombardiers de l'otan qui se sont tous
reposer sans encombre au petit jour sur
les bases alliés en italie
devant ces images tournées ce matin par
la télévision certes dans la banlieue de
belgrade
on ne peut que constater l'efficacité
des raids de la nuit dernière sur place
le témoignage de catherine monnet
évaluer les dégâts exacts et objectifs
purement militaires la population civile
commençait même être affectés par les
frappes de l'otan
le bombardement des ponts des routes ne
gêne pas seulement l'armée c'est aussi
toute l'économie qui est en train d'être
progressivement paralysé pour l'instant
les prix des produits de base continuent
de grimper il reste de l'essence même si
elle est toujours réquisitionnée mais
tout le monde est conscient que bientôt
il y aura de réelle pénurie
en attendant les belgradois son
redescendu cet après midi dans la rue
pour assister au traditionnel concert
quotidien depuis le début des frappes
aériennes
une façon de montrer officiellement au
monde que ces bombardements ne les
intimide pas également touché la nuit
dernière par les avions de l'otan
cette fabrique de tabac à aniche à 220
km au sud de la capitale d'hugo slave il
y a quatre jours le gouvernement de
belgrade avait demandé à cette usine de
doubler sa production pour faire face à
la surconsommation desserte de la
capitale et des autres grandes villes
durant ces périodes de guerre ce pont
enjambant la rivière ibar au sud de la
serbie a aussi été touché il s'agit dans
la destruction de ce type d'objectif de
coupé les voies de communication vers le
kosovo afin d'enrayer l'envoi de
renforts serbe vers la province
27 cible au total ont été visés la nuit
dernière dans toute la yougoslavie sur
cette carte les principaux sites touchés
par les missiles le kosovo n'a pas été
épargné
les raids ont été menés contre des
immeubles ou des maisons de christina
occupée par les miliciens serbes à la
suite de la destruction de leurs
casernements et l'exode des kosovars le
kosovo où l'armée yougoslave a dispersé
camoufler ces deux-là des ans les
plaçant en position défensive pour les
déloger
l'otan a demandé le renfort des
hélicoptères américains antichar apache
qui pourrait intervenir selon
ce française dans les prochaines 48
heures des hélicoptères que l'on
surnomme les douleurs de chars alerte
aérienne à belgrade il y à quelques
minutes les bombardements vont donc
reprendre ses bombardements répétés
auraient été je dis bien auraient été
condamnés par monsieur ibrahim rugova le
chef me dirait des albanais du kosovo
toujours sous forte surveillance des
policiers serbes
monsieur hugo va ainsi reçu
l'ambassadeur de russie puis le vice
premier ministre serbe et ses deux
rencontres au cours desquelles
thurgovien aurait demandé à se rendre à
l'étranger ont fait l'objet d' images
diffusés et rediffusés par la télévision
de belgrade
l'intensification de l'action militaire
de l'otan mise en place d'une logistique
humanitaire les etats-unis et leurs
alliés tentent ainsi de recentrer une
stratégie qui sommes depuis plus de 10
jours avoir sous-estimé la situation
rappelle et commentaire d'eric monnier
avec josé voulait ce texte dans les
semaines précédant l'offensive à
bruxelles la doctrine clinton l'a
emporté la doctrine clinton c'est la
guerre oui mais avec le moins de
victimes possibles côté a dit l'alliance
atlantique bombardera donc la fédération
yougoslave son déployer de troupes au
sol les plans définissent des cibles les
plus simples et plus visible ou
cherchent à éviter les victimes civiles
les missiles touche les infrastructures
et le matériel de l'armée serbe
les stratèges prévoit une campagne
longue en 1991 pendant la guerre du
golfe
l'aviation alliée avec mu et la défense
irakienne six semaines durant avant un
engagement terrestre
derrière cette stratégie il ya un parc
l'otan espère que ces dommages vont
avoir raison de la détermination des
officiers serbes que ceux ci vont
pousser le président milosevic a négocié
celle inverse qui se produit
les généraux contestataires sont
remplacés slobodan milosevic a choisi le
terrain il lance sa police et les
milices pour vider une partie du kosovo
de sa population albanophone chasse les
humanitaires sont dépassés par l'ampleur
de l'x au départ c'était en effet des
réfugiés qui choisissait de partir
notamment parce qu'il y avait des
bombardements et puis aussi des
exactions dans les villages dans un
deuxième temps ça a été une déportation
organisée par les forces serbes qui ont
préféré emmener les réfugiés vers
l'albanie
et puis ensuite qui a organisé des
trains de déportation vers la macédoine
ça on était présents frontières le plus
rapidement possible c'était l'urgence
mais encore une fois les humanitaires ne
peuvent pas faire l'impossible et à
cette échelle là il n'y a que les
militaires qui peuvent donner un maximum
dead dans le minimum de temps
imprévisible situation politique et
militaire disposait pourtant de signes
200000 kosovares avaient déjà quitté la
province fuyant les exactions et
belgrade avaient massé quarante mille
hommes supplémentaires au kosovo alors
même que les négociations se
poursuivaient à rambouillet
et puis il y a le précédent bosniaques
une épuration ethnique à grande échelle
malgré les doutes sur son efficacité
l'alliance persiste aujourd'hui à
privilégier son option purement aérienne
au risque de voir certains membres de
l'otan de la région la grèce et la
hongrie notamment fragilisé par cette
stratégie à bruxelles jean marc il use
donc d'abord le durcissement de l'action
militaire dès ce soir encore de
nouvelles frappes
oui claude durcissement de l'action
militaire non seulement en raison de
l'amélioration de la météo mais aussi un
durcissement perceptible depuis
plusieurs jours à travers le choix des
cibles nombre et cible et la volonté de
l'otan de paralyser les voies de
communication qu'elle soit fluvial
aéroportuaires ou routières alors le
problème c'est que cette stratégie est
aujourd'hui les porte parole de l'otan
l'ont presque sans ambages retenue ne
permet pas en tout cas pas encore
d'empêcher les forces serbes de
pratiquer ce que l'on appelle désormais
ici je cite la déportation massive des
populations du kosovo
quelle alternative maintenant pour
l'otan vient le problème c'est que si
une alternative existe n'est pas prête
elle suppose des décisions politiques
extrêmement rapide car d'ici vingt
vingtaine de jours il n'y aura plus de
kosovars d'origine albanaise au kosovo
alors sachez que si l'on veut organiser
une opération terrestre puisque c'est
bien de cela qu'il s'agit
il faut par exemple des chars lourds des
chars lourds qu'il faudra trois ou six
semaines pour acheminer sur place sur
place où il faut savoir où aller m il
faut savoir qui va accepter de les
recevoir
autant dire que raccompagner chez eux
les populations du kosovo réfugiés ce
qui a cours actuellement le but officiel
de l'otan eh bien il faudra du temps
l'apparition des hélicoptères apache si
on les utilise probablement dans les
prochains jours pourra permettre de
limiter les dégâts tout au plus merci
jean marc cette accélération de
l'engagement militaire de l'otan se
percevait dès aujourd'hui en italie sur
la base aérienne d'aviano où les avions
notamment les chasseurs bombardiers ont
effectué de nombreux décalages ces
dernières minutes encore reportage
anne chalvron dominique merdes 18h30
quatre chasseurs bombardiers f 16 de
l'escadrille 25,5 de l'us air force
prennent leur envol départ d'aviano
destination la yougoslavie sans plus de
précisions
l'opération a été soigneusement préparée
au cours des trois heures précédentes
sous l'oeil vigilant du chef
d'escadrille des goldfein tout a été
vérifié dans les moindres détails le
cockpit et tout son électronique
l'armement ces rubans rouges seront
tirés juste avant le décollage
amorçant ainsi les bombes l'escadrille
555 est une des plus prestigieux de
l'armée de l'air américaine il s'est
battu sur tous les fronts son chef n'a
pas d'états d'âme
notre cause est juste et la surélever se
sont unis pour aboutir à la victoire
nous sommes donc là pour le temps qu'il
faudra mais nous vaincrons avoir pris le
décollage le viano ce soit depuis 18 ans
les activités derrière moi en vérité la
météo s'est améliorée sur le kosovo et
les activités aériennes ont repris en
intensité
parmi les manifestations nombreuses
contre l'opération de l'otan serbie on a
compté plusieurs milliers de personnes
de nouveau en grèce athènes et puis en
crète mais aussi en allemagne à
francfort et à berlin
les manifestants réclament la fin des
bombardements et une solution politique
au kosovo sur le sort des centaines de
milliers de réfugiés il ya donc en cours
une opération internationale de
transfert de réfugiés vers des pays
comme les etats-unis l'allemagne la
turquie ou encore la suède mais la
france ne souhaite pas entériner une
situation d'exode voulu par le régime de
monsieur milosevic avec l'italie et la
grande bretagne la france veut
privilégier l'aide sur place
explications et gérard griesbeck ils
sont 151 exactement pour ces kosovars le
cauchemar est fini
direction la turquie l'évacuation de
milliers de réfugiés a donc commencé
selon le hcr les départs vont se faire
de skopje en macédoine mais aussi de
thessalonique en grèce que les kosovars
rejoindront en bus car l'aéroport de
skopje est trop petit
on prévoit quatre avions par jour soit
cent mille réfugiés d'ici un mois
de nombreux pays sont prêts à les
accueillir il s'agit du canada des états
unis de la norvège de l'allemagne de
l'autriche du portugal de la grèce et de
la turquie
emma bonino commissaire européen à
l'aide humanitaire a même réclamé une
carte d'identité provisoire pour les
réfugiés afin que l'on puisse identifier
ceux qui kiffent le kosovo et leur
permettent d'y revenir en jour mais
l'alliance atlantique est divisé la
france refuse d'accueillir en masse des
réfugiés kosovars
c'est ce qu'a dit hier au soir lionel
jospin et ce pour des raisons politiques
fondamentalement je crois qu'il est très
important pour nous tous pour l'opinion
de bien comprendre que l'objectif c'est
que ces hommes et ces femmes retournent
chez eux nous n'acceptons pas le fait
accompli de ces déportations telles
qu'elles ont été perpétrés jusqu'à
maintenant
l'italie aussi est réticente chacun se
souvient des milliers d'albanais
débarquant à brindisi il ya deux ans le
gouvernement insiste pour que les
réfugiés soient secours ou sur place
d'autres voix discordantes se font
entendre c'est le cas du ministre
britanniques clare short qui se trouve
en macédoine et qui a déclaré que
déplacer les gens hors de la région
reviendrait à faire exactement ce que
veut milosevic alors à contrecoeur le
gouvernement britannique s'est résolu à
accueillir des réfugiés
il a lancé une attaque sévère contre le
président yougoslave seront plus précis
et nous les décrire ont comme des
déportés et qu'on observe ce sont
effectivement des masques de déportés à
une échelle que l'europe n'a jamais vu
depuis l'époque de staline et hitler
ce soir on attend un nouveau départ de
réfugiés cette fois pour la norvège
anna kouchner bonsoir c'est absurde de
dire on va en déporté sur scène hier 40
milliards les etats-unis vers
l'allemagne vous trouvez ça absurde
comme la solution pour passer absurde
mais je pense que c'est cautionner
c'est une caution apportée à la
politique de monsieur milosevic
nous faisons des quotas nous enlevons de
la région des réfugiés des déportés les
gens qu'on a forcé à quitter leur maison
on a brûlé on a enlevé leur mémoire on a
brûlé leur carte d'identité et leur
contrat de mariage etc
et évidemment cette diaspora sera
beaucoup plus difficile à aider à
retourner chez elles et donc nous
choisissons mais c'était l'argument
également du président de l'albanie qui
est aux premières loges d'aider
massivement et la france le fait vous
avez vu le point aérien de nos forces
armées massivement des médecins des
médicaments de l'aide je crois que dans
un premier temps ce serait tout à fait
préférable de laisser l'espoir à ces
gens du retour ils ont droit au retour
ils ont droit à notre solidarité c'est
un devoir bien sûr je crois qu'ils ont
droit au retour et on connaît les
précédents historiques de cette
dispersion
concrètement l'aide française c'est quoi
partir dans les jours qui viennent vous
avez déjà un peu planifiée oui nous
avons une séance de travail nous avons
réfléchi avec le premier ministre hier
qu'il annoncera d'ailleurs
donc il y a un plan français d'aidé
humanitaire avec toute la panoplie qui a
été demandée au cours de la france
jourdain coordonnée comme avec les
anglais avec l'union rien sur il est le
plus souvent coordonnées vous l'avez vu
avec les allemands ou l'a vu avec les
italiens sur place bien sûr il est
coordonné c'est très difficile la
coordination c'est ce qui est plus
difficile dans une opération comme celle
là il faut de l'urgence d'abord pour
prendre en charge
serrez vous savez que la file et de
dizaines de kilomètres vers les
frontières n'est ce pas et donc il faut
que ces hommes et ces femmes chasse et
déportés soit abrité pour un temps et
puis je crois que ça s'organise et en
effet on verra que la france y prend une
part très active avec sous la
responsabilité donc que cette cellule de
crise du ministère des affaires de cette
cellule d'urgence parlant du ministère
des affaires étrangères moi je ne
m'occupe que de l'apparition même
bernard kouchner
nous sommes nous alliés de l'otan
responsable un peu de cesser ces vagues
de réfugiés si on avait privilégié une
autre option que les bombardements il
aurait peut-être pas autant de réfugiés
non à la lgv à lui en macédoine ont
seulement je ne crois pas nous en sommes
moralement responsable et c'est monsieur
milosevic qui les a fait partir le
revolver sur la tempe et on verra enfin
quant à ce qu'on sait déjà là les gens
s'enfuient non c'est pas pour ça qu'il
s'enfuit il s'enfuit parce que les
policiers ou les les soldats serre sont
venus les menacer ou les tuer on
découvrira que tout ça a été planifié je
sais déjà qui a eu des exactions et
crimes contre l'humanité devant c'est
vrai on verra que la liste était fait
on verra qu'il ya eu des dizaines et je
n'espère pas qu'on puisse prouver cela
parce que ça voudrait dire des milliers
de morts non ça n'est pas la force de
frappe de l'otan'' que ces gens fuient
leur pays était là-bas au kosovo et ils
doivent rentrer ce qu'il fuit c'est
cette répression sauvage on n'avait pas
revu d'exemple depuis nous sommes peinés
des khmers rouges une ville vidée comme
celle là est un pays c'est à dire que la
cuvette doit être vide
comment peut-on accepter cela au coeur
de l'europe et je sais comme c'est
difficile d'expliquer ça à nos amis car
nous avons évidemment tous des amis
serbes
il ne croit pas il ne crois pas parce
que comment pouvait-on imaginer on
l'accuse d'un prat d'impréparation
l'action humanitaire
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu penser
imaginer que des réfugiés se
précipiteraient vers les frontières mais
en masse comme celle là tout le pays
mais le plus démoniaque de tous les
dictateurs n'aurait jamais mais que
naulleau menzah pour eux bernard
kouchner ingérence humanitaire l'art là
il ya ingérence et militaires et
humanitaires non mais c'est la même
chose
qu'est ce que cette loi sur yohann gène
pas j'aurais souhaité qu'on le fasse
avant pour protéger ces gens parce que
l'ingérence pour moi c'est à dire la
protection des minorités les droits de
l'homme ou dessus des souverainetés
d'état la protection des faibles à
protection un pays souverain et à la
serbie dans ce pays souverain en effet
au dessus des souverainetés d'état
respectable lorsqu'elles sont respectés
lorsqu'elles sont respectables il y a
les droits de l'homme
on n'a pas le droit dans notre fin de
siècle d'assassiner une minorité le
droit d'ingérence
c'est à titre préventif et là
malheureusement
souvenez-vous au sortir de la bosnie on
l'avait dit mais quand même c'est en
effet une démonstration d'une confiance
et d'une morale internationale ont dit
catastrophe humanitaire mais la
catastrophe
d'abord j'espère qu'elle ne se produira
pas maintenant je crois que on prend les
choses en main la communauté
internationale
mais avant tout c'est plus qu'un drame
c'est une catastrophe humaine politique
c'est moral qui à la fin de ce siècle
aurait pu penser à cela
merci bien en convenir si vous voulez
apporter votre aide aux populations
réfugiées lui que ce jour sachez que
france télévisions et la croix rouge ont
décidé d'unir leurs efforts alors voici
les coordonnées pour apporter votre aide
croix rouge française réfugiés kosovo bp
3 semblent à peu sa france en 75 008
paris et vous retrouverez ça sur le site
internet de france télévisions ou par
minitel ou part en nous écrivant à
france télévisions pour aider la croix
rouge française en faveur des
populations réfugiés du kosovo
et puis ce matin à noter dans le journal
le figaro une quinzaine de députés
français membre du rpr de l'udf et
démocratie libérale réclamé la démission
des ministres communistes hostile aux
frappes de l'otan c'est une question
d'unité nationale pour les signataires
de ce texte
vous n'êtes pas trop j'ai d'être côtoyer
des ministres qui sont contre l'action
alors que genève non je suis pas gêné je
crois que dans ce gouvernement la parole
était libre mais une fois que la
décision a été prise par le premier
ministre il y à une action entamée qui
ne se démentira pas non je pense que sur
un sujet aussi important et vous même la
question que vous me posiez à propos de
nos responsabilités pourquoi ses
ministres une bassesse de noeux cela
poserait t-il pas mais ils n'ont pas
menacé de démissionner ils sont
solidaires avec l'action du gouvernement
que les partis bougent
selon leur idéologie et selon leurs
sentiments pourquoi pas dans une période
aussi difficile il faut beaucoup
expliquer vous savez c'est pas simple à
comprendre tous les soirs oui je sais
mais le poids historique du kosovo par
rapport aux serbes c'est difficile à
dire et puis enfin à paris a eu à
l'appel du mouvement des jeunes
gaullistes l'union des jeunes pour le
progrès du gip et plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui ont manifesté pour
dénoncer la politique d'épuration menée
par le régime serbe de monsieur
milosevic parmi les fûts manifestants
l'écrivain albanais ismail kadaré
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo cet
après-midi à la haye aux pays bas deux
hommes de libyens sont arrivés ils sont
présumés coupables de l'attentât commis
en décembre 88 contre un avion de la
panam qui s'était écrasé à lockerbie en
écosse
il y eu 270 morts pendant dix ans le
colonel libyen kadhafi
refusait de les remettre à la justice la
pression notamment de monsieur nelson
mandela la fessée des commentaires
stéphane waite nerfs ils ont quitté
tripoli ce matin comme des héros en
brandissant le v de la victoire
abdel al megrahi et l'amène fima deux
agents secrets libyens montent dans
l'avion de l'onu qui les amène aux pays
bas ils seront jugés dans cette base
militaire transformée en tribunal un
procès exceptionnel puisque ce sont des
magistrats écossais qui siégeront un
procès sur l'une des actions terroristes
les plus meurtrières de l'histoire 21
décembre 1988
le vol 103 de la panam vient de quitter
londres à 10000 mètres d'altitude en
pleine traversée de l'ecosse
le boeing explose au dessus du village
de lockerbie bilan 270 morts en majorité
des américains
le fbi a il se tourner très rapidement
vers la libye le chef de l'état muamar
kadhafi est suspecté d'accueillir des
bases terroristes dans son pays
mais kadhafi qui a toujours nié être à
l'origine de l'attentât refusent de
coopérer
en 1991 un tribunal écossais désigne al
megrahi et fima responsables de
l'attentât
kadhafi refuse leur extradition l'onu
décident alors d'un embargo très sévère
contre la libye le mois dernier kadhafi
se décide enfin à coopérer le parlement
vote l'extradition des deux hommes à
condition qu'ils soient jugés dans un
pays neutre
ce ne sont donc ni les états unis ni les
causes qui accueilleront le procès mais
les pays bas en milieu d'après midi
les deux suspects sont arrivés sur le
sol néerlandais une arrivée discrète et
sous haute surveillance
en livrant les deux hommes la libye a
tenu sa parole
l'onu a bien reçu le message riboud mme
perrichon
je vais très rapidement envoyé un
rapport au président du conseil de
sécurité pour confirmer que les deux
suspects sont arrivés au pays bas et
qu'ils sont désormais entre les mains
des autorités néerlandaises
le conseil devra suspendre immédiatement
les sanctions
selon des diplomates occidentaux ces
sanctions ont été levées en fin d'après
midi leur levée totale dépend maintenant
d'un vote du conseil de sécurité qui
doit intervenir dans un délai de trois
mois
le procès des deux suspects lui devrait
durer près d'un an un an et demi
guerdane levée des sanctions
effectivement à dos nu mais les états
unis font bande à part quand même et
c'est un succès pour monsieur kofi annan
oui c'est d'abord la fin d'un long bras
de fer entre la libye et la communauté
internationale et puis c'est un
soulagement palpable ici aux nations
unies les nations unies qui et c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire depuis l'irak et
puis le kosovo plus récemment s'était
retrouvé sur la touche
kofi annan vous le savez s'était
impliqué très personnellement pour
tenter de trouver une issue à cette
crise en disant décembre dernier il
s'était rendu à tripoli où il avait sans
succès tenté de convaincre mouammar
kadhafi d'extrader les deux suspects
quelques jours plus tard c'est lui qui
demandait à nelson mandela le président
sud africain ainsi que l'arabie saoudite
de se joindre à ses efforts
les sanctions ont été imposées à la
libye en avril 92
elles ont été suspendues mais elles ne
sont pas encore levés le conseil de
sécurité effectivement se donne trois
mois pour décider de la levée définitive
de ces sanctions et la france ne
manquera sans doute pas d'ailleurs de
poser quelques questions posées des
conditions concernant notamment
l'enquète sur le vol lutter à 772 on dit
ici que le rapport remis par kofi annan
contiendrait quelques nouvelles
informations à ce sujet mais sans aucune
précision pour l'instant
merci dominique en algérie dans la
perspective des élections
présidentielles du 15 avril prochain la
semaine prochaine quatre candidats se
sont associés pour dénoncer dans un
communiqué commun la partialité de
l'administration en faveur de monsieur
bouteflika également qu'adam candidat
est donné favori
les quatre signataires qui défendent
pourtant des idées très différentes volt
ainsi prévenir les fraudes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
thierry thulliez et bruno girodon trop
c'est trop
ils ont même interrompu leur propre
campagne dans le pays pour se retrouver
cela se passe au siège d'un des partis
d'opposition à l'exception du leader
historique hocine aït ahmed dit tim d'un
malaise cardiaque il ya là tous ceux
dont la candidature a donné à l'élection
sa crédibilité
leur mise en garde de pouvoir a donc
fait l'effet d'un coup de tonnerre
avant même le vote les voilà qu'ils
dénoncent déjà l'engagement de l'état en
faveur d'un seul candidat qui serait
celui de l'armée les moyens de
l'administration s'en est utilisée au
profit de monsieur vous tirera les
services de sécurité les histoires
d'affichage
un tag indices nous poursuivons le
combat contre la fraude pour des
élections libres transparentes
alors là parler des pressions qui
s'exerçaient séraphin nombre d'agents
tous menace de se retirer de la campagne
ce qui inquiète bien sûr l'homme choisi
par le gouvernement algérien pour
garantir la régularité du scrutin
nous sommes joue les nuits taraudé par
le syndrome de la fraude
c'est très bien d'ailleurs en un sens
parce que j'estime que ça va nous faire
redoubler de vigilance
bon nombre d'algériens sont persuadés
que les jeux sont déjà faits
et que les habitudes du passé vont
finalement l'emporter 15 avril les
candidats à l'élection ont décidément
beaucoup de travail devant te pour
convaincre des électeurs sceptiques que
leur vote peut changer les choses en
algérie en france dans un quartier de
bayonne la police aurait découvert plus
de 200 kg d'explosifs et quelques armes
dont des lance roquettes
il s'agirait d'une cache de
l'organisation séparatiste basque eta
on a appris aujourd'hui le décès de
monsieur ambroise roux l'ancien
président de la compagnie générale
d'électricité était âgé de 77 ans on le
présentait comme l'éminence grise du
patronat français ayant un rôle
déterminant dans les nominations
industrielles et financières
mais si ambroise roux était une grande
figure du capitalisme a souligné le
président jacques chirac qui leur a
rendu hommage ce soir
sport football demain demi finales de
coupes d'europe marseille reçoit le club
italien de bologne la composition de
l'équipe marseillaise des pas encore
définitive l'entraîneur de l'om rolland
courbis cultive le goût de l'inattendu
pour lui l'enjeu est grand car il n'a
jamais gagné en tant qu'entraîneur un
titre européen
portrait réalisé par florent gautreau et
philippe deslandes
courbis est rarement là où on attend
qu'il soit en ce matin ensoleillé en
aboul chercher on ne voit guère que son
fidèle adjoint jacques 24 schaefer
courbis l'ancien défenseur de marseille
monaco ou toulon maîtrise toujours l'art
du contre-pied il est pourtant bien là
en civil il observe et domine même la
situation si loin et si proche à la fois
tous les joueurs vous le diront si l'om
est une famille courbis en est le chef
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est que
j'essaie d'apporter à mes joueurs ce que
j'aurais aimé qu'un entraîneur ma porte
c'est pas plus c'est pas plus compliqué
que ça capte pas mgmt à courbis
rencontre ordinaire il parle même
remplaçant mais
je trouve que c'est surtout remplaçable
qu'il faut parler et à ceux qui jouent
moins souvent que les autres
tout droit sorti d'un roman de pagnol
courbis parle beaucoup trop disent ses
détracteurs qui affirme qu'il n'a rien
gagné en tant qu'entraîneur il répond
qu'à toulon ou bordeaux il a toujours
tirer le meilleur des équipes qu'il a
dirigées interdit de casino
cet homme aux amitiés controversé ne
cesse pourtant de jouer et ils gagnent
souvent l'om est deuxième en championnat
et demi-finaliste de la coupe d'europe
mais ils râlent toujours contre roger
lemerre accusé de fatigue et les joueurs
de l'om en équipe de france pour
l'instauration d'un deuxième arbitre un
vieux cheval de bataille
le système d'arbitrage je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est dommage et que le
principal acteur d'un match de football
neuf fois sur dix ce soit l'arbitré donc
pas l'arrière central le gardien de but
le paradoxe lui colle à la peau ce
marseillais pur souche réside à monaco à
marseille vit à l'hôtel la vie
d'entraîneur halonen et passionnante
mais dangereuse
je me vois pas débarquer à marseille qui
en plus l'endroit où qui a qui a eu
peut-être le plus grand nombre d'entrées
leur prendre rendez vous et comme
architecte pour faire construire une
maison et et être virés avant même
qu'ils aient terminé le plat les
supporters marseillais eux ont déjà les
plans de la statue qui dirigeront si
l'om devient champion d'europe poursuit
son rêve
ils voudraient bien continuer son
bonhomme de chemin sous le soleil de
marseille avant de refermer ce journal
je rappelle les informations concernant
la frappe de les frappes de l'otan en ce
moment même boucle seront tout d'abord
la situation des réfugiés dans les camps
lé camp notamment en albanie en
macédoine et le monténégro on est entre
350 à 400 mille personnes qui
actuellement se réfugier dans ces camps
et dans les pays voisins du kosovo
l'hygiène dans ces camps est
particulièrement redoutable difficile
dramatique l'aide alimentaire un point
aérien s'est organisée mais quelquefois
cela se fait un petit peu dans la
pagaille pour l'instant les
organisations humanitaires arrivent sur
place
la france a déjà dépêché un certain
nombre d'avions et cela va continuer
nous l'a confirmé le président albanais
concernant les frappes de l'otan elles
se poursuivent en ce moment même elles
ont été très fortes beaucoup plus forte
que ces derniers jours la nuit dernière
enfin l'arrivée à la haye pour être jugé
de deux suspects libyens deux hommes
présumés coupables de l'attentât commis
en décembre 88 contre un avion de la
panam
l'avion s'était écrasé en écosse à
lockerbie cet accident d'avion cet
attentat avait fait 270 morts
le procès pourrait s'ouvrir d'ici
quelques mois et l'onu a décidé de
suspendre les sanctions qui avait été
prise contre la libye du colonel kadhafi
dans un instant la météo avec nathalie
rihouet à 22h55 d'un monde à l'autre le
magazine de paul amar s'intéressera aux
enfants de banlieue à l'occasion de la
sortie du film de jacques doillon petit
frère et puis à 0 heures 50 le journal
de la nuit vous sera présentée par
laurence ostolaza suivi du cercle de
philippe lefait demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra emma
bonino commissaire européen à l'aide
humanitaire en duplex de bruxelles
et puis à 13h vous retrouverez rachid
arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci